for a 16 year old annie farmer a trip to
jeffrey epstein's new mexico ranch was a
window of opportunity a chance to mix
with a billionaire and his girlfriend
she described glenn maxwell as trim
attractive and well-dressed she hoped
they could help her pay for university
25 years later ms farmer was reliving
that trip in court
she described alleged abuse by ms
maxwell which began with a massage ms
farmer said she pulled the sheet down
and exposed my breasts and started
rubbing on my chest and upper breasts
the door to the room was open i had this
sense that he could see me
ms farmer told the court that on another
occasion epstein crawled into bed with
her
i remember being in bed in the morning
she said and epstein suddenly opening my
door and bounding into the room in a
playful way and said he wanted a cuddle
he climbed into bed and pressed his body
against me asked why she didn't say she
didn't want to cuddle and he responded i
was aware i was isolated on the ranch
with these two people
annie farmer was the fourth and final of
glenn maxwell's accusers to testify in
this trial prosecutors hoped they'd
saved their most compelling and
consistent witness until last certainly
her reliability was helped by the fact
that she'd kept teenage diaries from
that time in one entry she describes
being weirded out by jeffrey epstein's
behaviour
glenn maxwell's siblings kevin and
isabel have been in court throughout
it's their sister on trial but jeffrey
epstein has never been far from
proceedings as the prosecution rests its
case they will hope they've done enough
to show the jury there are two abusers
in the picture martha calmer sky news
new york